[Music]
if I seem cocky or confident or all on
stage this evening it is only because of
all the participation trophies I want as
a child that's what's keeping me going
which you could probably tell just to
look at me because I don't want to brag
but since high school I have maintained
my flawless participants physique my
life is wonderful ladies and gentleman
I'm in a wonderful long-term
relationship which is amazing because in
2016 if you're not if you're just dating
casually someone can break up with you
simply by not texting back
welcome to the future it's worse than
science fiction thought it happened to
my friend she was like Josh I went on
three dates with a guy I thought it was
going great then I never heard from them
again he ghosted on me that's the word
for that ghosting which is the wrong
term for that phenomenon because that is
not how ghosts behave if there's a ghost
in your life he stays in touch he's
gonna bang your pots and pans together
flick your lights on and off if you're
telling me a story that ends he ghosted
on me you've got to come with a better
tale than that that story's gotta go
Josh I went on three dates with a guy I
thought it was going great
now every night at the stroke of 12:00 I
hear a blood-curdling scream that I
don't understand like oh no he ghosted
on you I'm so sorry to hear that
or it could be like Josh I was flirting
with a woman online I thought I'd show
up for the first date in person be a
gentleman old-school I rang the doorbell
answering the door was an old woman
sobbing I was like oh I'm sorry is
Meghan there she was like Meghan
Meghan's been dead for 30 years dude you
got ghost it and that is a bummer but
you should not have signed up for tinder
on that burial ground your call no one
else's my girlfriend and I just went to
visit my parents he recently retired and
when we showed up my dad was wearing
suspenders and sweatpants which is to
retired I didn't make fun of them to his
face because I'm a good son but I did
text my sister immediately because I'm a
great brother that's me I was like hey
Jen dad started dressing like a gym
teacher attending a funeral she got it
but I felt guilty I felt guilty as soon
as I sent that text because I realized
when you're retired suspenders
sweatpants that is the ideal outfit for
you to wear because that tells anyone
you meet everything they need to know
about your life
the suspenders sate of the world I'd
like to speak to your manager and the
sweatpants say and I have all day don't
worry what I'm doing later nothing
jeopardy bed it was always a pleasure to
visit my folks I love older relatives I
love old people in general everything
about him I love that they were long
sleeves and long pants all year round
like their skin can't touch the air like
they're all made of avocado a lot of
people say old folks are racist I don't
think that's true I don't think old
people are any more prejudiced than you
or I I just think they think they're
still whispering
I'll be out in public with my
grandmother she'll say something well
meaning but horrendous Oh Joshua look at
that lovely oriental couple oh dear God
Nana you need to turn up your hearing
aid cuz we're in public and the future
she doesn't mean any harm she's just
using the word they learned to talk
about race when she learned how to talk
roughly 100 years ago so whenever she
does that give her Newark to bring her
into the 21st century so she can speak
publicly the problem is she's 89 years
old which is amazing the Roman numeral
for her age is a complete sentence but
what that also means is she doesn't have
a lot of time left doesn't want to waste
it studying flashcards so every time she
screws up I give her the same
inoffensive word for any group of people
it's not the right thing to do is just
convenient for me every time she screws
up I go no no no no no Nana nowadays we
call those people bloggers cuz she
doesn't know what that word means and
she'll say it because she loves and
trusts me her only grandson and the best
part for her is no matter how outdated
the old lady nonsense she spouts is no
one's gonna get mad right she could be
out in public like no granddaughter of
Mines gonna date a lazy blogger or
in 15 years the bloggers will control
our entire economy people walking by her
just like wow that lady really gets it
she knows what direction this world is
going in
you